like one of the most difficult choices i  ever faced uh in life  was it was in 2008  and um i think it had uh  like maybe 30 million left  or 30 or 41 left in 2008 i had two  choices  i could put it all into one company  and then the other company would  definitely die or split it  between the two companies and but if i  split it between two companies  they both might die  [Music]  and when you put your blood sweat and  tears into creating something  you're building something it's like a  child  and so it's like which one am i going to  let one stop to death  i can bring myself to do it so i split  the money between the two  unfortunately thank goodness you need to  make the big decisions in life with your  heart  and the small ones with the head